Speaker 1: This is something a little different.
I don't think anybody has covered this.
OK, because one of our viewers, Tanner, wrote
to me and said, hey, David, big fan of the
show.
After seeing many of the ridiculous responses
to mask mandates across the country, I decided
to see if this is happening at my local school
board.
I watched the most recent meeting and was
not disappointed.
I have attached a video in which a middle
school student and her dad both quote Hitler
during their anti mask presentations to the
school board.
This is really wacky stuff.
OK, I'm going to play this for you.
This is the Thompson School District.
They claim to be the 17th largest school district
in Colorado.
They claim to have about 15000 students under
their purview.
You really have to see this.
This is my daughter and then dad who quote
Hitler in their opposition to masking and
the crowd cheers.
It's crazy.
This is Charlotte and Thomas.
We're starting with Charlotte here.
This is very depressing.
Let's take a look.
And by the way, I apologize about the audio
quality.
It's very harsh.
Speaker 2: Hi, my name is Kate, I am from
Berthon, I like start my address with a quote
from a famous politician here alone who owns
the Youth Games, The Future.
Speaker 1: OK, the famous politician she's
referring to is Adolf Hitler.
Just so people know, quoting Hitler.
Speaker 2: I was a student at Turner Middle
School, I say was because I had to leave your
school district because of how your teachers
were treating.
The second week I was there, you made a ask
my name.
I don't know where I'm at because I had medical
conditions that make it so I can't wear masks.
And because of that, I was segregated and
sent to the library.
When I attempted to use my rights to speak
freely, I read the 14th and 15th Amendment.
My constitution was ripped out of my hand
and when I tried to video what the staff were
doing, the teacher took my phone.
Speaker 1: I mean, is this so the sad thing
here is all of this language about my rights
were taken away.
I was trying to cite amendments from the Constitution.
A kid doesn't come up with this stuff by themselves
and you'll see when the dad comes up exactly
where it's coming from.
Is this a form of child abuse?
I mean, you know, Fourteenth Amendment granting
all persons born and naturalized in the U.S.
a guarantee of equal protection, 15th Amendment,
the right of citizens to vote, shall not be
denied or abridged on the basis of race, color
or previous condition of servitude.
What mask's guys come on and she continues,
Speaker 2: then just make it even better.
The teacher said I was a terrible person and
I was a child.
Then she told me I was going to kill everyone
in school and to quote the same politician
again, if you tell a big enough lie and tell
her enough, it will be believed
Speaker 3: the
Speaker 1: same politician.
That's Adolf Hitler.
Again, that's she's quoting Hitler.
Speaker 2: You say that you're supposed to
keep a student safe from the big bad bullies,
but you and your teachers are bullying me
and all those students in the district.
How does that work?
All of your students let to be a lot of your
students that because of those actions and
when I tried to show myself my fellow form,
the teachers took in, ripped it to pieces,
destroying my property.
When I was in school, I had to go home multiple
days because I had massive headaches due to
the masks, the classrooms and the classroom
being above 90 degrees when I used to love
school.
But now I don't.
You have ruined school for me and fortunately,
it's too late.
It's too late for me, but I will fight for
all the other kids in your school district,
including my older sister.
I hope you're happy now that you ruined my
my love for school.
And one last time to quote the famous politician,
Adolf Hitler.
When diplomacy ends, war begins.
Thank you for all your consideration.
Speaker 1: So quoting Hitler three times there
now, I'm not making fun of this girl, I see
her as a victim.
I see her as a victim probably of this guy,
the dad.
OK, here comes the dad.
We're going to pick up his comments in progress,
as I guess we might say.
Speaker 4: And they do teaching.
We have a problem.
We have a problem when we have board members,
family and friends calling in to further their
agenda.
That problem starts here.
The problem starts with this board member
who refuses to believe the children when they
are mistreated abroad, who serve our children
to mask mandates for 18 million dollars.
How much will it cost to sell our children
into mandatory vaccines?
What else are you willing to sell our children
into?
How many children have to be mistreated, abused
or assaulted before the board is willing to
look into an incident?
Your mission statement is mindless drivel.
It is here a lip service to this community
that makes you feel good about what you do.
I have lost faith in this board and based
on your staff and your actions, you do not
have.
Speaker 1: I assume he means you lost faith
in the board, not lost face.
Losing face is something different.
Speaker 4: Children's best interests at heart.
With that said, I call for the immediate resignation
of everyone on this board.
Speaker 1: A lot of resignation people.
Just everybody is calling for resignations
these days.
Speaker 4: We have no confidence in you.
We have no trust in you.
And you have not shown one ounce of diplomacy.
And like my daughter said, when there's no
diplomacy, there is more.
Speaker 1: And even staring down the members
of the school board there, so so like father,
like daughter.
Both quoting Hitler in their anti mask screeds.
Again, I see the daughter as a victim.
And I see this all really I mean, we we can't
attack this kid.
This kid got the idea of being like this from
somewhere and you see exactly where it came
from.
This is really sad stuff.
And unfortunately, these types of presentations
are likely not going away anytime soon.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
You can submit submit videos of your local
school board meeting if you want to info at
David Pakman dot com, we'll cover them.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is disproportionately
funded by folks like you who sign up on our
website, get a membership and I guess just
revel in all of the great membership perks
that are available.
You can sign up at join Pakman Dotcom and
you can use the coupon code better.
Twenty one to get a big discount.